hey everyone I'm Ilana or Charl Amazon
and you are watching my channel today is
a QA which is a highly requested video
for you guys that I am doing to
celebrate 10000 subscribe it oh my god I
know it seems like a really small amount
compared to a lot of people but it's big
amount to me I remember when I got like
a hundred subscribers and I was like
hang on there are a hundred people who
willingly watch my videos to say
questions Ryan has asked when did you
first discover your love for videogames
I don't remember and neither do my
parents so this is off to a great start
I'm pretty sure I was fault Louis asked
if you have to pick one game weld or
cartoon slash anime well to live in
which would it be and why I hate to be
horribly cliche here but I'm going to be
and I'm gonna pick Pokemon the things I
would do to earn and arcanine Jordan has
asked what was your first experience
with writing slash journalism and what
attracted you to it
specifically reviews and stuff I started
because I had a tumblr and people would
just ask what I thought of games and I
realized that I really liked replying
and analyzing games so that's why that
sort of started intellectual badass has
asked if you could say anything to the
developers of any game what would you
say and why I would say it to rare why
Alexes asked what's your favorite game
so I find this question so hard to
answer and I can't even comprehend how
some people answer it so easily because
there are so many games that win
something awesome like us was that I
loved the ending of that game but when I
think about the best experience that
I've had with the game or the one that I
remember the most playing through not
necessarily the best game it's Deadly
Premonition
when i was playing that i was dreaming
about it I was talking to everyone about
it but I was just crazy about that while
I was playing it Gordon has asked in a
recent weight loss how did you go about
it did you set specific diet and macros
or just a hell of a lot of cardio no
diet I have no idea what macros are and
I've actually do no cardio because I
absolutely hate it basically I just did
it by weight lifting doing like two to
three hours exercise a day sometimes
less and cutting out crappy food
Jacob Oz asked who is the one Fame
person you want dead sarah silverman
adrian has asked as a kid did you think
you'd become a video game journalist
absolutely not but it did might occur to
me I remember thinking holy crap someone
writes the reviews in this magazine that
would be an amazing job and it's
actually a magazine that I have now
written a review in so that feels pretty
awesome but it was one of those things
that had occurred to me but always
seemed impossible and when I was younger
I actually wanted to be a lawyer Damien
has asked if you died tomorrow thanks
Damien do you what do you think people
would say about you and how would they
remember you um I guess people would
remember me by my videos because they're
easy to find and I guess people would
say I was ambitious I think that's a
really defining part of who I am Josh
asks how did you get into art I just
started drawing like everyone else did
in school and just started doing it
outside of school I've never had any
professional training that's why a lot
of the time my art isn't perfect so
whenever someone comments and it's like
oh the proportions wrong and I'm like
thank you I know I just don't have the
skills to fix that I'm aware that
there's a floor that thanks for
reminding me that I suck Charlaine was
not fans asked what is your first memory
of gaming see this is once again really
hard but I think my first memory is the
game motor racing and I distinctly
remember when you start up the game it
asks you to put your name in and I
remember the way the guy yells it and he
goes Angie your name I haven't played
that game in so long but I just can't
get that voice out of my head and I
don't think I'll ever forget it and
that's it for me today everyone I will
definitely be getting back on track and
making videos every week so remember to
subscribe and I hope you guys liked my
Q&A fine